hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled a multi-omics approach to
detection and characterization of viral
pathogens and their impact to the immune
system this webinar is part of an
ongoing coronavirus virtual webinar
series i'm susie valdez of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
blue time for more information about
blue times go to wwe.com now let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits simply
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speakers
dr. Andrew Kwang a chief science officer
at blooood I'm and mr. bill hunt the
director of micro fluidics product
management at fluid on for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
Phil and Andrew you may now begin your
presentation welcome gentlemen
good morning thank you for joining us
today to hear about blue x solutions to
the challenges that we are facing with
SARS could be - infection and the health
challenges associated with managing
patients that are showing kovat 19
pneumonia as all of you know this is a
very large-scale
health issue affecting almost all
countries worldwide in addition to the
impact of course that it has on patients
and those infected with this virus there
are significant impacts on first
responders the infrastructure for
hospitals the access and supply of PPE
and a dire need for additional tools and
tests for detection as well as
therapeutic strategies for treatment of
patients that are suffering from this
infection one of the things that we have
identified that is important are the
rapid and high throughput genetic and
epigenetic testing both for the virus
and for hosts response immune and
serology monitoring of antibodies and
how the patient's immune system is
responding to the infection and finally
as part of serological testing measuring
the antibody response to infection or
from vaccines to be and serve as
surrogate markers for
evaluating how we can move people back
into the workplace or into a safe place
for them to recover
technical requirements that are needed
for a large number of these molecular
diagnostics are really the high volume
and the applications both for viral
detection and for biomarkers and these
biomarkers can be epigenetic changes to
the patient that is infected or can be
changes in the immune cell population of
the individual the other requirement
that is important to address is really
maximizing the results from these
precious samples there are a large
number of possible molecular tests that
one can perform and it's important to be
able to perform these tests with a small
amount of sample as possible to evaluate
the broad breadth of tests that are
available and finally purely because of
the scale of testing there needs to be
high cost efficiency in in testing
so the support that flew time is
offering in global laboratory efforts in
response to this disease is through hi
clex math cytometry and imaging this is
based on our proven scientific side Toph
technology our versatile scalable micro
fluidics platforms that can be used for
measuring both genetic and protein
changes through our partnerships with
different companies and our ability to
design flexible panels so that one can
very easily add additional biomarkers to
existing panels without changing the
technology and really we offer
simplified workflows and automated
platforms to improve ones productivity
and really driving the return on this
investment to answer these critical
questions associated with kovat 19 so
very briefly fluid i'm offers
multi-omics solutions for a
comprehensive view of health and
different states of disease it's based
on essentially two platforms
the first is mass cytometry which is
illustrated on the top part of the slide
and we have both the original site off
technology that was initially
established for looking at samples in
suspension similar to what one would see
in fluorescent based flow cytometry
however with the addition of the
technology that cycle allows you
basically a mass spectrometry based
method one can broaden the spectrum of
markers that one considers in a study
from the few that you can do in
traditional fluorescent based methods
for flow to up to 40 to 50 in the case
of mass cytometry
with the addition of the Hyperion
product which is an imaging module works
very closely with the Helios our current
mass cytometry instrument one can also
do sub cellular imaging of tissues at
about 1 micron resolution with
approximately 40 different markers on
the other side of the house we have our
micro fluidics platform which allows for
a very flexible and powerful method to
look at different genetic and genomic
markers within a wide range of clinical
samples and in addition to that we have
our single-cell techniques for looking
at both changes in the genetics genomics
and proteins both of these are based on
our micro fluidics technology which was
the foundation of the technology that
was developed at fluid I'm
you
so the primary two technologies that
we'll be talking about in today's
presentation are the use of math
cytometry in immune monitoring and
genomics and gene expression studies
using our micro fluidics platform to
evaluate possible infection and
epigenetic changes in the patient that
has been infected with this virus
you
first off we will have a presentation on
our micro fluidics platforms and how you
can use this in the context of research
for Cogan 19 and Bill Hunt the director
of micro fluidics from fluid I'm will be
presenting this part of the slide deck
where he'll be talking about
microfluidic solutions for detection and
characterization of human and viral
genomes
thanks Andrew
so welcome everybody it enter noted I'll
be presenting the genomics and the micro
fluidics portion of today's presentation
and then pass it back to Andrew for the
math cytometry component of this of the
presentation and I'd like to start this
particular section by acknowledging the
rapid pace at which information and the
disease is spreading globally it started
back in the end of December that's those
when first cases were reported in Wuhan
China and it has since spread globally
at a rapid pace the virus has been known
by a few names it seems to be in
following treatments we're going with
SARS Coby - at the moment but it's also
been referred to as novel coronavirus or
n Co V - 19 for simplicity I'll just
refer to the virus as SARS - through
today's presentation and the disease
itself is referred to as Kovac 19 I also
want to recognize the vast number of
resources that have become available
with regard to Koba 19 and stuff and the
study of SARS - I'm using the WHO
database as a reference for today's
presentation and acknowledge that the
numbers are changing on a daily basis
but I do find it as a useful tool to
just monitor hot spots and the
epicenters of disease at any given
moment in time which is the who website
is as a wonderful job doing but there's
also additional resources available such
as Johns Hopkins University and CDC
but as you can see the number of
infections is now over 700,000 as of
this morning with over 33,000 deaths and
the countries hit hardest in terms of
cases and deaths are from the US at the
top of the list through some countries
in Europe Italy and Spain specifically
as well as Germany and of course China
has been hard hit by this by this
disease
moving into the genetic that the
genetics of SARS - so it's classified as
the genus beta corona virus and it's
also the same genus that is that
contains the original SARS virus that
was an outbreak in the early 2000s as
well as the MERS Coby corona virus that
was an outbreak in the 2010s the genome
is a positive sense single-stranded
polyadenylated RNA with about 30,000
base pairs and the sequence has been
referenced and it's posted to gene Bank
and the link is shown here on the slide
there are four major structural proteins
including the spike glycoprotein which
has been a target for therapy and
vaccines since it is the mechanism by
which the virus enters host cells and
results in ensuing infection but there
are also targets such as the envelope
protein the membrane proteins and the
nucleic acid and I show at the bottom of
the screen the reference to the three
pathogenic strain the three human
pathogenic strains of corona virus SARS
one stars two and the MERS virus the
Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome
and they're very close phylogenetically
as you might expect
moving into how fluid iams products can
help in the detection and study of kovat
19 we offer a variety of products both
on the pcr side and on the library prep
side I'll start with the technology that
would enable screening and detection so
in this case we're looking at a
qualitative result whether the virus is
present or absent we can also look to
see if a certain genotype is present or
absent then you can progress to a
quantitative type of an approach more of
a viral load approach that's
traditionally used with HIV or have
separate I to c4 means of quantitating
how much virus happens to be present in
an individual at any given time and
these technology these methods are all
based on PCR assays transitioning over
to clinical research there's a lot of
work being done in this space at the
moment as a lot of information remains
to be discovered about this virus such
as viral evolution so looking at
phylogenetic analysis there's a lot of
work being done on mechanisms of action
such as population stratification which
individuals are succumbing more readily
to this virus versus those that have
perhaps a healthier immune response and
are able to combat the virus more
effectively that's an area of interest
globally there's also an interest in the
transmission of the virus its level of
virulence the host response response to
the virus or post resistance as I
mentioned as well as virus acceptability
what compounds may be developed that can
effectively combat and eradicate the
virus from its host
and per these there's a combination of
technologies available to us we can also
use the pcr technologies used for
screening and detection but there's also
a lot of work on next-generation
sequencing
looking at the fluid on portfolio of
genomic analysis systems it really
occupies four sectors as shown in this
slide we have our instrument systems
which is the Juno which is our Universal
controller and it's also used for
library prep library preparation for
next-generation sequencing and then we
have our bio mark system which is our
Universal qPCR system or Universal PCR
system and I'll describe a little bit
more about that in an upcoming slide we
have our integrated fluidic circuits
which are the device that is the form
for all of our reactions that are done
on blue and I'm instrument systems we
make reagents that are used with the
integrated fluidic systems and then we
have our design service d3 which can
create custom designs for use with our
reagent technology
focusing on the genomics platforms
themselves I mentioned the Geno system
is a component that that serves multiple
purposes we refer to it as a preparatory
system meaning that it supports library
preparation for targeted sequencing but
it's also a universal controller so by
that I mean you can take any of fluid
iams portfolio of ifcs
and you can load them for processing on
the Junot platform it will accept all of
our formats and that includes formats
that are used specifically and solely on
the Juna platform but also those IFC's
that can be transferred over to the
biomark system for analysis
through qpcr and that's what's shown in
the figure here on the right so on the
biomark side the bio mark has our optics
and data analysis software that supports
gene expression genotyping copy number
analysis as well as digital PCR on the
library prep side on the left side of
the slide we have you can feed our
libraries into Illumina systems for
purposes of next-generation sequencing
and it also supports RNA seek which
we'll get to in a moment
since I mentioned the integrated fluidic
circuit is a is a touchstone of our
technology it really does it really is
the the mechanism by which all of our
all of our reactions are realized so in
terms of keeping pace with the virus
such our pathogen such as SARS - this
device is designed to enable automated
high throughput workflows with rapid
turnaround time it also allows us to
scale throughput without changing
technologies and processing up to
thousands of samples per instrument per
day then this particular skin schematic
I'm showing you a one ninety two twenty
four dynamic array IFC and if you break
down the nomenclature of our ifcs the
digit on the left refers to the number
of samples you can process in a single
IFC run the digit to the right of the
decimal refers to the number of assays
or acid pools in the case of library
prep that can be performed on the same
IFC
the nice feature about these devices is
that you can add remove or replace
assays on demand because they ask these
enough pre fixed or pre spotted that
gives a lot of flexibility for
especially for rapidly evolving
pathogens if you need to add additional
primers in the coming weeks or coming
months it's probably easy to do so with
this format and then the final point is
that it you can analyze multiple
pathogenic and controlled targets
simultaneously
to identify the source of respiratory
diseases that share common symptoms
which is important in the case of code
19 since it does share a lot of symptoms
with other other common respiratory
pathogens such as flu and pneumonia
one of the elements of our integrated
fluidic circuits is the cost savings I'm
Andrew mentioned the importance of
trying to control or contain costs when
you're testing large numbers of samples
and a rapid amount of time one of the
nice things we do is we compare
ourselves to the traditional microtiter
plates which are common tools used in
clinical labs around the world and if
you take if you compare one for one it's
possible to generate several thousand
reactions with a single IFC but here
we're showing a 96 96 dynamic array IFC
so again 96 samples 96 assays and
they're all tested combinatorially on
that platform and you can test you can
test one IFC to get 96 or you can use
one IFC to process the equivalent of 96
96 well plates or it's the equivalent of
24 384 well plates so you're getting
thousands of reactions with a single
single run
our d3 a/c design portal is set up to
provide custom content for a variety of
targets including respiratory pathogen
analyses so the design designed assays
are specific for coronavirus using
publicly available genomic reference
sequences and primer designs you can get
the full NCIS NCBI reference sequence as
shown in this figure and we can get we
have targets that are specific to the
bike the spike protein as well as the M
and ng D gene sequences can also be
targeted
we also can design assays for specific
channels of respiratory panel of
pathogens so for example we have
developed we have received requests for
human or no ortho pneumonia virus
subgroup a through NC and that that has
been generated with our design group and
it's publicly available
so to do this the mechanisms to process
3d three are to email the ASCII design
group for assistance and I shows the
email link on the screen or you can
contact your local flu and I'm sales
representative or field application
scientists for additional information
moving into the actual products that go
with different platforms I'll start with
our with our bio mark products since
there have been a lot of interest in
rapid testing hype throughput screening
and surveillance and that's how our bio
mark system would be used so in
combination with the bio mark you can
have our IFC's that support planet ated
pcr for rapid detection giving results
in less than four hours and I can show
on the table below the instrument the
assortment of IFC formats that are
available from the 192 24 that I showed
previously down to a 48 48 again 48
samples 48 assays for each of those 48
samples
it also supports high volume screening
so you can test up to thousands of
samples per day with flexible batch
sizes as samples come in you can either
scale up from the 48 to the 96 to the
192 depending on demand and it has the
adaptable assay content I mentioned that
you can add remove replace assays on as
needed and that's one of the nice
features we promote with this device
since it does provide a great deal of
flexibility and this is useful when
you're trying to develop panels if you
want to add different targets remove
different targets it's useful to to make
those exchanges readily
and then you can test it's being used to
test pathogenic strains of coronavirus
if you wanted to look at which strains
or pathogenic versus the other strains
that are associated more with the common
cold versus a wider range of respiratory
pathogens that go beyond just the corona
virus
for digital PCR the instrument also
supports digital PCR beyond just the
quantitative PCR and here I'm showing
the table with two of our digital a
digital array from IFC's
the 12 X 765 or the 48 by 770 and these
are also useful for sensitive absolute
quantitation so you can get sensitive
viral detection using quantitative
digital PCR with in-line fluorescence
detection supporting up to 12 recording
up to 48 samples per run with up to 770
partitions per sample
the workflow is is very quick you get
results in less than three hours and
it's very flexible users can prepare one
or more sample pre mixes using gene
specific assays of interest allowing you
to either process all samples within
with the same assay for process samples
with different assays
there have been a number of publications
on the biomark platform the ones I'll
show today are applicable since they
fall in the same area of looking at
pathogen detection so this particular
paper comes from a group in France it
was published in 2018 and the title is
disclosing respiratory co-infections
a broad range panel assay for avian
respiratory pathogens on a nano fluidic
pcr platform so I recognize this is a
bird model but it does show the proof
and principle of creating a
high-throughput screening protocol to
detect respiratory co-infection profiles
in poultry so for this study they use
the bio mark HD they use the HX
controller versus the Juno that I talked
about earlier which is specific to the
IFC type so the eggs X controller is
specific to the 96 96 dynamic array IFC
and the authors concluded that the
protocol enabled development of a
high-throughput multiplex panel
targeting key poultry respiratory
pathogens that included virus bacteria
and fungal targets so it was proven
principle that the system does support
this type of a workflow extending this
into humans there was an additional
publication that came out in 2016 also
from a group in France titled a novel
high-throughput method for molecular
detection of human pathogenic viruses
using a nano fluidic real-time pcr
system and in this case the authors
wanted to develop a high throughput
method for detecting 19 human pathogenic
viruses and controls at the same time
and they also use the bio mark HD and in
addition to our dynamic array IFC's the
48 48 in this case they also used the 48
dot 7 7 0 digital array IFC which
supports digital PCR and they concluded
that the combined use of real-time PCR
as well as digital PCR provided
high-throughput sample screening during
a outbreak investigation and
surveillance so that seems definitely
applicable in the case of coronavirus
these the types of things that
institutions are trying to do today so
the fact that it's been done before
using bio mark using our reagents using
our ifcs
improvement principal shows how it can
be extended and adapted to up
such as coded 19 or perhaps other
outbreaks in the future
ichael threaded several other
publications they're actually thousands
of publications generated for the bio
mark system I'm focusing today on the
pathogen detection applications so in
addition to the two that I highlighted
earlier these are some additional
publications that I thought were
relevant that might be of interest
specifically noting the last one which
was relevant to or was applicable to
coronavirus authors in Turkey we're
looking at the impact of viral
replication using different plant
extracts and found that certain extracts
did seem to slow drede plication of the
virus so that's something I would
certainly want replicated but it does
show how creative in how we how the bio
mark system in our reagents and products
are being used in creative ways to to
solve cancer questions and solve unmet
needs
we have been engaging with customers who
have contacted us with regard to using
our products to combat the virus and
understand its conduct surveillance and
perform detection we announced earlier
this month a collaboration with the
Icahn School of Medicine at Mount Sinai
and this was a press release from
mid-march they are leading a consortium
to develop real-time PCR tests for
coronavirus using the bio mark HD they
are using the 192 24 and the 96 96 ifcs
as well as Roche Universal probe library
products and their goal is multiplex
epigenetic and RNA measurements to
support high-throughput screening and
detection during and post infection so
the goal here is to see if there are
targets and biomarkers that will allow
individuals who perhaps have not yet
presented with symptoms but yet they are
infected with virus if we're able to
detect them earlier in the cycle and can
get them to the proper level of care
and this is being planned as a
submission to the US FDA for the
Emergencies authorization and more on
this will be coming in the coming weeks
from from Mount Sinai
moving into our library prep products
and solutions I wanted to start start
out with our advanced RNA seek NGS
library prep workflow which does enable
czars to analysis
it supports automated what walk away
automation substantially reduces
pipetting steps and operator infrared
interventions using the automated 4 th
sample workflow that includes solid
phase capture of polyadenylated RNA
which the SARS - virus is polyadenylated
it offers superior cost savings allowing
you to maximize laboratory budget by
minimizing consumption of reagents and
consumables using microfluidics
technology and it supports robust
chemistry chemistry allowing you to
competently generate high-quality
full-length stranded RNA sequences of
sequencing libraries from a variety of
organisms including SARS to
to support this workflow we developed a
new IFC format which was introduced in
2019 called the 48 Atlas on this IFC
format supports solid phase capture and
multi-step reactions but it was part of
our goal to automate more of the
workflow than prior ifcs have done but
in our goal is going to have a
continuous evolution and creation of
ifcs
to meet the needs of our users so in
this case you can see that there are a
number of steps that have all been
automated on this IFC format so it truly
is walk away automation
and for analysis of copán 19 there have
been some papers and publications on
this very topic looking at how coded 19
in the host gene expression changes
within the same sample so in the case of
this publication gene expression
analysis was deemed critical to
understanding the host immune response
to corona virus infection the three
targeted viruses associated with
pathogenic corona viruses of all they
all have positive-sense single-stranded
RNA genomes where the polyadenylated
tail and because of this of the corona
virus RNA and the host cell mRNA can be
profiled together in the same RNA seek
workflow so an example of this you can
see how this might be used for
hypothesis free measurements of
phenotypic changes and cells or tissues
in response to viral infection it can
also be used for characterization of the
immune the immune cell gene expression
in patients at different time points
after viral infection it can be used for
characterization of Kovach 19 sequence
variants and the impact on host gene
expression and finally identification of
immune cell expression signatures that
correlate with clinical solutions or
clinical outcome to guide frequent salud
options
that concludes the genomics portion of
the presentation I will now pass this
back to Andrew who will present the
mastoid hama tree component of our
portfolio Andrew
thank you Bill
so what I'd like to share with you is
some work that's been done in the area
of cytometry in Co good 19 research
we've seen over the past few weeks or
month or two a variety of papers using
traditional cytometry techniques that
really demonstrates the importance of
doing large-scale longitudinal immune
cell profiling of individuals that are
infected with with SARS Co v2 in a
recent commentary published by the
President of Isaac the International
Society for the Advancement of cytometry
he noted that the starting point for
addressing multiple clinical questions
will really rely on the ability to
deeply characterize the immune system of
individuals that are affected with SARS
Co v2 he showed a small amount of data
which is illustrated on the panel on the
right of a patient that was infected
with SARS Co v2 and you can see a
distinct change in the immune cell
profile well this is very suggestive of
the importance of psychometry proko good
19 research we've also seen some
additional papers where they performed
clinical studies and the use of
cytometry has unveiled new insights into
mechanisms of action and how one can
potentially treat the disease
effectively
this paper by zing at all published in
cellular and molecular immunology they
were able to demonstrate through the use
of cytometry that they could identify
the changes in a variety of immune cell
populations on a single-cell basis and
in addition to elucidating the changes
in the immune cell populations they also
had flow cytometry panels that added
functional analysis and so one could
look at both the change in the state of
the cells as well as the changes in the
immune cell populations
although this study showed the potential
of things there were some difficulties
in carrying out this study because of
the large number of parameters
subpopulations and function they were
required to actually analyze the
clinical samples from each individual on
five different runs in the flow
cytometer
this of course can lead to biases in the
results and you cannot really
necessarily correlate the different cell
populations because of the variability
of running multiple samples from the
same patient due to the variability of
these fluorescent based technologies
what we illustrate here are the five
different panels or analyses that were
run in this particular study on the
first two we illustrate the antibodies
that were used for the core part of the
panel which allows one to elucidate the
different cell populations in addition
to understanding what the cell
populations are they looked at T cell
activation and exhaustion in two
separate panels and then they looked at
two other functional panels that were
related to cytokine release which we
know plays an important role in the
morbidity of this disease in all of
these panels you see that CD 3 cd4 and
cd8 had to be included multiple times to
allow one to basically align the data
and so this leads to a lot of challenges
and some missing information for example
when you look at the CD 45 for the CD 56
populations you don't have the
information that's associated with your
functional markers for markers of
activation or exhaustion
to overcome these particular challenges
if you were to have done the exact same
assay with 23 unique markers using mass
cytometry rather than fluorescent based
month net excuse me
rather than fluorescent based cytometry
you would be able to perform the
experiment in the single tube and which
would lead to more robust results
leading to different insights
potentially and of course the savings of
time and resources both for the
instrument and for the time for doing
the analysis
in a very interesting paper that came
out of China they looked the
transplantation of ace to negative
mesenchymal stem cells and how that
would impact the outcome of patients
with koban 19 not on yet in this paper
they used a very large 36 marker site
off panel to aid in understanding the
changes to the immune system upon
treatment with these mesenchymal stem
cells what they found was that the
mesenchymal stem cells transplantation
could improve the outcome of the
patients and that the unbiased
psychoanalysis because of the large
marker panel and in conjunction with the
measurement of the 8 cytokines they
found that the tea and natural killer
cell subsets will reduce post
transplantation as well as a reduction
in the populations of the dendritic
cells and the regulatory t-cells so this
had a very large impact in reducing the
cytokine storm which was leading to a
better outcome for these patients that
receive transplant what was important is
the system's level analysis was enabled
by mass spectometry because of the large
number of markers they were able to
actually move this into the clinic very
quickly even though this was a
relatively new panel for them because of
the simplicity of panel design that is
associated with using mass cytometry
so what are the challenges as we look
forward into doing larger scale
longitudinal immune cell profiling for
people and studies that are associated
with Kovan 19 well the first of course
is panel design so one of the challenges
associated with traditional fluorescent
based methods is that there are
combinations of markers and fluorophores
that will work together very well while
others will not for example it's often
difficult to look at both the surface
marker and an intracellular marker at
the same time and so the question arises
when I design my panel in order to make
this fit into my particular instrument
are there biases that I will have to or
rather assumptions that I will have to
make regarding the different cell
populations
addition with the approach of multiple
tubes you will have the trade-offs
between a larger number of markers and a
larger number of hypotheses that you
will test versus minimizing your sample
use for other studies you know
potentially or serology or for studies
similar to what bill described in his
previous slides and of course processing
all of the tubes will take a lot of time
and it's not a cost effective nor
efficient way of performing these
studies and even the data acquisition
may be very doable with a large number
of data files that come off of the flow
cytometer that analysis and able to
bring all of that data together will be
very time consuming and in the
challenges that we're facing with the
large numbers in the growing burden of
this disease one needs to be able to
generate answers very quickly we're also
seeing the beginning of a lot of
multi-site collaborations we know that
there are differences from region to
region and so questions for flow
cytometry are how one can enable
multi-site collaborations so that we can
have data that can not be dependent on
site collection
and finally we have found that a lot of
customers are interested in having one
or two laboratories in a larger
consortium perform the analysis and so
there are questions around how does one
store samples and how to ship them to
the laboratories that will be performing
the cytometry analysis
so the solution that fluid on provides
is the max par direct immune profiling
system this is really a two piece
solution one is a 30 marker backbone
panel its lieth alized in a dry single
tube format which is easily customizable
and the staining protocol is very
straightforward
because it's done in a single tube the
requirements are relatively modest
in that you only need three hundred
microliters of full blood or
approximately 3 million PBMCs to perform
this very comprehensive profiling of the
immune system it's cost-effective and
very efficient as I said the staining is
very very simple and then at a single
analysis on the Helios mass cytometer
the second part of the system is the max
power path setter software which allows
one to remove analytical bias and the
need for expert gating this is a
end-to-end workflow from the 30 marker
backbone panel all the way through to
the generation of a standardized report
the max power direct immune profiling
system has been demonstrated to have
very good consistency from lot to lot
run to run and between sites in addition
to the study that we initially
demonstrated this very good consistency
there have been peer-reviewed papers
that also really demonstrate the power
of math cytometry to bring consistency
to these multi-site collaborations we've
also seen the ability to stain cells
with a max power direct immune profiling
assay and then immediately freeze these
samples and then store them up to 4
months and analysis after the four
months of freezing basically
recapitulates the results from the
samples that were analyzed initially
upon staining without freezing
so the max part direct immune profile
and that it overcomes many of the
challenges associated with traditional
flow cytometry by moving to a mass
cytometry based method rather than a
fuller essence based method it's a very
easy workflow it is very fast to move
from sample to answer you can freeze and
ship your samples and most importantly
as you have a large number of folks that
will be performing these multi-site
studies you do not have to have special
expertise for the data analytics
in addition to the 37 cell populations
that are addressable with the 30 marker
backbone panel we have additional open
channels to customize the panel
what's illustrated in green are the
availability of additional antibodies
from fluid ID that you can immediately
drop in to the assay as well as the open
channels from 105 up to 116 where you
can perform custom conjugations of the
cadmium medals to your antibodies of
choice to allow you to really expand the
panel out to well over 40 markers
the next power path setter software will
allow you to customize your assay so
when you add in the additional drop-in
markers or either additional sub
populations or for understanding cell
function this can be accommodated with
accustomed workflow solution through
path setter
to demonstrate the ability to do a
multi-site study with max power direct
there was paper recently published in
cytometry Part B where they looked at
the variability associated with the next
part direct immune profiling si both
with PBMCs and with whole blood and they
found that for either of these samples
the coefficient of variation was less
than 18 percent where it was slightly
better in whole blood than it was in
PBMCs that maximal variation was when
you looked at the differences across
multiple sites they included six sites
for PBMCs and seven sites for whole
blood so this was run on different
instruments with different operators and
at different times so the
reproducibility of the SI is excellent
and will allow for very accurate
measurements of the changes in the
immune systems of patients infected with
SARS Co v2
recently fluid item has announced the
ability to analyze samples for customers
through the launch of the therapeutic
insights laboratory this is a
full-service laboratory that will allow
you to design a particular essay based
on the backbone of Mac's part direct and
have the samples shipped to fluid on for
analysis and a very quick turnaround of
a full report for use in studies so the
therapeutic insights laboratory allows
you to perform both suspension based
math cytometry experiments as well as
imaging Meza Tama tree experiments and
it allows folks to very quickly bring
this technology to their clinical
studies even if there is no access in
the group working on these immune
profiling studies if they don't have an
instrument
the masks are direct immune profiling
system we believe is a very powerful
solution for your code 19 research needs
when it comes to understanding
longitudinal immune cell profiling the
systems-level panel really reduces bias
and doesn't force you to make
assumptions or to compromise on the
choice of immune cells that you want to
look at in the particular studies there
is very good run to run reproducibility
it maintains the contextual relationship
between all of the different subsets and
the functional markers and we believe it
solves most of the multi-site challenges
associated with variability and sample
processing for these very large-scale
immune profiling studies
so as we know everyone is challenged in
being able to you know get information
you can learn more about all of the
products that we offer both on the side
of the mass cytometry product offerings
as well as the offerings in
microfluidics at our website fluid I'm
Tom thank you
you
and thank you Andrew and bill for the
formative presentation we will now start
the Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen so let's get
started we have quite a few questions
coming in today I'm going to start with
you Bill
our first question is actually a
two-part question how long is the
process for using the microfluidic
platform for detection and FDA FDA now
has approved 5-minute testing for covin
19 detection for added how does this
system compare to yours
I'll start with the first part of it so
our workflows depend that they vary
depending on the IFC itself and as well
as the protocol you choose the script
that's chosen to run the IFC so we have
specific scripts that support relatively
short turnaround times of just a couple
hours and we have others that have to go
longer but they're all less than four
hours in total one of the things we
promote about our technology is the
capacity of Prue put so if you look at
our IFC structure we can go up to 192
samples at a time and if you're talking
about a couple hour runs runtime you
were able to get thousands of samples in
a day so that's how that number was
calculated for the second part of the
question yeah this is not a this is not
a point-of-care test it's not a
five-minute test like the Abbott test
that was developed with the old earlier
technology but it is it is high
throughput and high capacity
you for that and another question built
some people are asymptomatic symptomatic
so the detection kits used now are not
perfect
to detect low viral load in each
individual so for quantitative viral
load what is the lowest concentration
you can detect
that's an active area of development for
us and with our customers so we've got
individuals who are working on viral
load applications using our technology I
know that based on other technologies
are based on standards the goal is to
get below five copies per reaction and I
certainly there are there are tests out
there that are going to come down
towards one or perhaps even less than
one copy per reaction so that's the
target we are aiming to achieve as well
thank you for that an answer this is a
question for you did this samples all
have to be fixed in like a smart buffer
foresight off the service you run no
they do not
we have the available we are able to
analyze samples that have been stained
and then frozen alternatively one can
actually stain and then preserve in in
something like smart tube we have not
tested MDI PA with cells or with blood
that have been preserved in in smart
tube before staining
thank you and still is I'm going to try
to ask ask this question right is that
mean we have nine two one six different
Argos 9216 different barcodes ah no it's
um so that's a good question what in
terms of the numbers I can see where
that number might be a little bit
confusing so the number that number the
9000 represents the number of reactions
if you're looking at our genotyping
IFC's if you take the 192 the 192 24 you
can get up to over 9,000 data points per
IFC run from that IFC but on bar codes
for library prep we have up to 1536
unique bar codes and that's with dual
indexing
and give her that and bill does the I
say mean a SNP yes if you're looking for
a snip or a single nucleotide
polymorphism or a single variant a
single nucleotide variant yes in the
individual assay is designed to target a
specific snip
I want to thank our audience for these
wonderful questions that are coming in a
great conversation though I'm going to
stick with you for a couple more minutes
how is detection of the corona virus
possible during the incubation period so
right now the group it may are the group
at Mount Sinai is looking at this and
they're trying to put together a group
of biomarkers both RNA base and
epigenetic based where we're looking at
the hosts response to the virus being
present in the system so right now we're
trying to understand what the it's more
of an illogical or a communal logical
response or perhaps as I said an
epigenetic response it might be a
methylation change in the host as a
result of the virus being present so
those are in addition to looking for the
virus itself looking for the direct
signature of the virus being its RNA
we're looking at the host reaction to
the virus being present
bill what types of micro fluidics does
this include
okay I'm not totally sure about that
question but I'll try to answer it the
way I think it's being asked so with our
with our system the micro fluidics
refers to just the structure the the
reaction chambers in the architecture of
our of our devices so we work with a
variety of samples so if you look
upstream of the the IFC itself or the
integrated fluidic circuit itself the
sample extraction is somewhat agnostic
we've worked with a variety of systems
to support the generation of purified
nucleic acid which serves as the input
for our for our reactions so we have
users who are using kits that are
commercially available from various
vendors with a manual operation we also
have larger institutions that have used
automated liquid handlers to do sample
extraction and sample preparation
upstream of the microfluidic device so
I'm hopefully that answers the question
but I have it can get follow up if
needed
sure Thank You villain regarding kids
which kit or protocol is used to extract
RNA from the swab
currently our customers internally we're
using a variety of commercial products I
know that there's a number on market
today so we're using the same ones that
other groups are using and certainly you
know we're in we are interested in
sample extractions so that may be an
area we turn our attention to in the
future
give her that and so does the fluid on
technology can't be used to help to
detect very low numbers of viral copies
in a person who is starting and
developing the coded 19 to see disease
can you explain how that's a wonderful
question that I think our researchers
are trying to understand as well so I
don't think we're there yet in being
able to give a definitive answer about
how exactly that will play out but that
certainly in this is an area of interest
in research because the ability to
detect the virus quickly will allow for
better pre odds of the individual
understanding what to do when you detect
a virus and somebody who's perhaps
asymptomatic that that I think will be
very important information but it's
still yet to be shown to my knowledge
that and I'm going to swing over to
Andrews got a couple of great questions
coming in for you Andrew
are there any Kovac 19 project using the
Mattel isotope labeled antibodies with
math symmetry and or is the fluorescent
labeling more suitable for this case so
be the last example that we gave the
study of the stem cell transplantation
the busines Connell stem cell transplant
with the h2 negative cells that was
actually a psycho study with 36 markers
and so the large advantage to that was
it was actually be able to be done in a
single panel as compared with some of
the other examples that we showed where
there were fewer markers 23 verses 36 in
this case and they actually had to run
that over five tubes we believe in
general there's advantages with metal
labeling of antibodies because of the
different techniques that are required
for performing intracellular staining
compared to looking at surface markers
and so and plus with the you know high
degree of Plex 'ti it's much easier to
design a panel using that cytometry with
the metal labeled antibodies
thank you for that and where's the
turnaround time for math photometry so
if you were to use the if you have
access to the instrument we said it's
very easy to actually take your samples
stained and analyzed within a single
afternoon and of course you have
multiple samples they would just stack
on top of each other so they the route
put of the assays is very high and it's
very quick to perform if one were to
send samples to our service laboratory
turnaround time would typically be a few
days after we had the study design done
of course this depends on the number of
samples and the startup time may be
significantly longer than that if for
example the investigators required
additional antibodies to be optimized
for the assay but if one were to use
things in the catalog would be very
quick turnaround time to get up and
running
thank you Andrew I'm going to swing back
to you bill and again audience members
thank you for these great questions
coming in what a wonderful interaction
we're having bill what is the detection
method used in the microfluidic system
we have a variety of chemistry's that we
support so fluid I'm offers snip type
chemistry which is a fluid I'm developed
chemistry for snip detection
we also offer Delta gene chemistry for
gene expression detection we also
support chemistry from other suppliers
so we have in we have users that have
applied TaqMan chemistry we're close to
our micro fluidics we've looked at
chemistry from IDT and so it's just a
matter of one finding chemistry's become
available if there's enough of a demand
and perhaps with collaboration with with
external partners we can start looking
to see how we may adapt those
chemistry's for use with our micro
fluidics
and how is this how can this be applied
to the broad population and is the cost
a limitation to use the technology
massively
so the cost part is one about we feel
it's one of our advantages because we're
working at such small concentrations and
such small volumes of material that the
reagent volume is a relative it can be a
large cost for many applications and
because we're using such small amounts
that brings the cost of an individual
reaction down our micro fluidics also
offers high throughput and high
multiplex capacity so we're able to
offer users a high amount of results in
the single batch run or a single test
run likewise we offer a lot of a lot of
data points for that each of those
samples so I mentioned on our 192 24 IFC
for as an example each of those 192
samples is interrogated by the 24 assays
within the dissenter matrix of the IFC
and that gets you to the number of data
points in total for the IFC run for our
library prep we also have that it's the
same type of combinatorial exercise but
each of those assay inlets represents a
pool of assays and for an individual
pool we can put hundreds of assays in a
given pool so you can get fairly complex
libraries for interrogation by next
generation sequencing
thank you and one more question bill
which epigenetic modifications are being
assessed DNA myelination I'm sorry
revelation small rnas or high stone
modifications that's that's an area that
we're waiting for input from Mount Sinai
that's the group that's working on this
on the application with a consortium of
labs they are affiliated with so they're
the ones who are coming up with the
content and we will work with them to
produce the assays based on the targets
they provide us
super that and Andrew let's come back to
you if in additional antibodies are
added to the max bar direct panel can
the automated software options still be
used yes
yep that's really one of the nice
features of the path sitter software is
that using the backbone of the
antibodies in the next part direct si
went in very easily add additional
antibodies to perform an answer you have
questions related to different cell
populations or questions around cell
function in fact we recently done this
for a customer who added quite a few
additional antibodies for their code in
nineteen studies
thank you and so are the full sequences
and ncbi freely available for
commercialization that's a great
question I believed so it certainly is
worth checking before anybody decides to
use them just I don't want to have legal
advice over a forum but I know that a
lot of institutions have been published
publicizing their primers and probes the
CDC has done so other institutions
around the world have done so many labs
are using those reference sequences as
part of their designs for their
laboratory developed tests which they
either run themselves or perhaps if you
even submit it as part of an emergency's
authorization exercise so it's it's
worth investigating but I believe they
are a public forum publicly provided
through that forum
and bill a couple more questions for you
I'm interested in using your RNA
sequence kit to profile virus presence
in different cell types there's your
system support a range of sample input
amounts and RNA quality it does so our
kit supports inputs of 10 to 100
nanograms of total RNA and we've also
demonstrated that it's we have really
good performance over a range of ren
values and rin is the RNA integrity
number
and I'm going to swing back to you bill
can I send frozen pea I'm sorry Andrew
can I send frozen PBMC samples to the
therapeutic insite services and have the
max par direct at a run on them yes you
can
okay and one more question for you
Andrew can you provide a copy of the
long 2020 paper
actually if you go to the website for
the journal which is aging and disease I
believe that you should be able to
access the article from the journal
itself
thank you so much and we have time for
about two more questions and I'm going
to swing back over to bill bill the
techniques mentioned in slide sticks are
used for every single sample from each
person or are they only a subset of
samples
so the I'd have to go back and look at
slide six I'm presuming that's the slide
with the micro fluidics but if it's
aware of our micro deck structure deck
oh it's a multi element question bill oh
okay
can you repeat the question then I
misinterpreted it sure the techniques
mentioned in slide sticks are they used
for every single sample from each person
or only a subset of samples I wonder
just because maybe a question for
Android then it's not a phobia micro
fluidics right so I think that the the
answer to the question is you were not
necessarily proposing that every sample
be analyzed
you know both with through with micro
fluidics or with with math cytometry it
really depends on the questions that
you're asking so clearly for a lot of
things that have bill presented the
midsection side that he talked about the
advantages of our micro fluidics
platform for doing things in high
throughput at relatively low cost for
questions around therapeutic
stratification disease progression when
once interested in the immune profiling
math cytometry would be you know a
particular interest and of course the
genomics platforms can be used for
looking at changes in viral load for the
epigenetic changes that are associated
with the changes of Manian system and so
I think it really depends on the
questions that one is trying to address
as people are looking at treatment and
detection and of course progression of
the disease
thank you and thank you both of you
Andrew and Bill for your time today and
your important research do you have any
final comments you want to provide the
audience numbers before we close today
I'm sure that we'd like it either go
ahead Andrew go ahead so Phil go I'm
sorry go ahead
now I appreciate everybody getting up
and participating in this these forums
are incredibly important nowadays in
light of everybody sheltering in place
and not having access to face-to-face
interactions which we're accustomed to
and I think many of us enjoy so being
able to reach out and have this kind of
engagement through virtual means is a
wonderful new tool for this space and I
hope that everybody stays safe on going
Andrew
I'm sorry I'm sorry did you want to also
say anything oh yeah I just wanted to
thank everyone for attending today's
presentation and we're happy to answer
any additional questions that you have I
know we weren't able to answer all the
questions that came in so we will try to
respond to all of you and we're very
excited to be playing our part in trying
to address this crisis in what we're
seeing worldwide
and thank you again both of you for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting question and
encourage you to go and interact in the
booth I'd also like to thank our
sponsors blue dime for sponsoring
today's webinar join them in their booth
today questions we do not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through the end of the year 2020 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available so replay we encourage
you to share this email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and next until next time bye
bye